meine damen und herren ich komme gerade
aus einer video-konferenz mit den
oberbürgermeistern und
oberbürgermeisterinnen der größten
stellt größten städte in deutschland
die eines gemeinsam haben nämlich doch
eine hohe und zum teil auch eine rapide
wachsende zahl an cholera infektion und
ich habe mich sehr gefreut dass die
stadt oberhalb da diese einladung
gefolgt sind und ich glaube dieses
gespräch war auch gerade jetzt sehr
wichtig wir haben uns unpassend
ausgetauscht und wir werden ihnen auch
ein gemeinsames papier zukommen lassen
ich will nur herausnehmen und
herausstreichen dass wir uns alle einig
waren dass wir bei instanzen von 35 pro
100000 aber vor allem dann bei 50 pro
100000 infizierten in sieben tagen
zusätzliche maßnahmen ergreifen müssen
und die der charakter dieser maßnahmen
ist immer darauf ausgerichtet die
kontakt nachverfolgung weiter auch
sicherzustellen
und deshalb werden beschränkungen
notwendig und hier geht es eigentlich um
eine ganze gruppe von beschränkungen die
von allen gleichermaßen gesehen wird
einmal das konsequente tragen von mund
nasen bedeckung auch in öffentlichen
räumen wo die abstandsregeln nicht
eingehalten werden könnten wie das ja
zum beispiel auch münchen schon gemacht
hat die einführung von kontakt
beschränkungen im öffentlichen raum und
zum beispiel durch einführung einer
sperrstunde und oder alkohol
beschränkung für gastronomiebetriebe
sowie weitergehende beschränkungen der
teilnahme teilnehmerzahlen über das
hinaus was wir auch schon mit den
ländern vereinbart hatten
die beschränkung also gerade in bei
veranstaltungen und feiern auch bei
feiern im privaten raum
es geht darum
die gesundheitsämter gut auszustatten
sich hier auch gegenseitig zu helfen an
dieser stelle ein herzliches dankeschön
an die bundeswehr
das wurde von allen als sehr sehr
wichtig eingeschätzt aber wir werden
auch weitere unterstützung
gemeinsam suchen genauso wie es um die
unterstützung und entlastung von
ordnungsämtern geht und wir haben uns
vereinbart dass wir uns in knapp zwei
wochen wieder zusammenschalten werden
und schauen wo wir mit den zusätzlichen
maßnahmen hingekommen sind das was wir
erreicht haben warum erst in knapp zwei
wochen wir brauchen das wissen wir aus
den maßnahmen im märz aber auch aus dem
was münchen jetzt zum beispiel schon
gemacht hat immer ungefähr mindestens
zehn tage bis wir sehen ob wir einen
abfallen der inzidenz auch wirklich
beobachten können und deshalb ist der
zeitpunkt in zwei wochen noch einmal
wieder zuschauen
der richtige wir alle spüren ja dass die
großstädte die ballungsräume jetzt der
schauplatz sind an dem sich zeigt ob wir
die pandemie in deutschland unter
kontrolle halten können so wie uns das
jetzt ja monate lang gelungen ist oder
ob uns diese kontrolle entgleitet und
genau an dem punkt sind wir jetzt mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren